the release of Dark Souls in 2011 came
with an intriguing comment by the game's
director hit otaku Miyazaki he suggested
that the player should choose either the
pendant or nothing as a starting gift to
enhance their experience and so a
crusade started a mission undertaken by
the game's most devoted players a quest
to find out what the pendant did it's
been almost a year now and nothing has
been found
players myself included have been
starting with the pendant dropping it in
certain places hitting every wall with
it in our possession trying to discover
the cryptic meaning of the pendant
surely it's something incredible there's
probably an amazing truth to the pendant
because the secret is hidden so well
that's why it's hidden so well
the person who finds the meaning will be
a hero in the Dark Souls community so
let's take a look at the clues the
description of the pendant states that
it has fond of it wait what's this when
it comes to the pendant I actually had a
little bit of an intention to play a
prank a prank a prank no God no God
please no no no